- [Vivek] Hi everyone.
Good morning. Welcome to Vegas.
Welcome to Advanced RAG Architectures.
It's a 400-level talk.
I'm Vivek Mittal.
I am AWS solution architect,
being here with AWS for around
three and a half years now
and based out of Tampa.
I'm part of AI/ML specialist group
and my focus area is building
applications using RAG
or retrieval-augmented generations.
So that's where we are.
I'll hand it over to
Pallavi, my co-speaker
so that she can start the session.
Thank you.
- [Pallavi] Fantastic. Thank you Vivek.
I should've done my speech
exercises this morning.
Good morning everyone. How is
everyone doing this morning?
Great?
Yeah. Do you feel energized
to be at re:Invent?
Yeah, it's always fun thing.
I mean, whenever I walk
through that hallway,
it's such a fun thing to do
when the music is going on,
you feel so precious and
it's just a fun time.
So my name is Pallavi Nargund.
I am a principal solutions
architect at AWS.
I have been in the IT industry
for about 25 plus years
and out of that,
around seven and a half
years I have been with AWS.
Like Vivek I'm part of the
AI/ML specialist group,
so I have been working
with Amazon SageMaker
for five plus years
and Bedrock for two plus years.
And one of the things
that I'm most passionate about
is the RAG architecture,
which is retrieval-augmented generation.
And that's what we are
going to talk about today.
But before I begin,
I just wanted to do a quick
check from the audience.
How many of you are familiar with RAG?
Excellent.
How many of you have put RAG
architectures in production?
Fantastic.
How many of you are struggling
with the RAG accuracy?
(Pallavi and Vivek chuckling)
Yes. So that's what we are
here to talk about today.
So the agenda is
first of all, this is a
400-level code talk session.
We're now going to be
presenting a lot on PowerPoint
and since the audience is fairly familiar
with RAG architectures,
we're not going to spend
too much time on the slides.
We will be going directly to the code.
We are going to have a quick overview
of Amazon Bedrock Knowledge Bases
since that's what we are
using to showcase our RAG
or how to improve the RAG accuracy.
How many of you are familiar
with Amazon Bedrock Knowledge Bases?
Okay, a few, which is good.
So we will have a brief overview
but throughout the code
we will be explaining the different APIs
and the different features
that are with the Bedrock Knowledge Bases.
Then we are going to discuss
advanced RAG technique
and we are going to do
the code walkthrough.
Now I know this is a RAG architecture
and improving the
accuracy of the responses.
I feel it's a science and art by itself.
I really love solving complex problems.
You will have questions.
We may not get to all the questions today
because we do wanna talk a
lot about RAG techniques,
but we are going to be
outside in the hallway.
So if we don't get to your
questions during the session,
feel free to reach out to us.
And if you are in between sessions
we are available on LinkedIn.
Send a direct message
and we'll meet you and
answer your questions.
But this is something Vivek
and I are passionate about.
We talk to our customers a lot
about solving different problems.
So we are happy to do that.
So the goal as I mentioned
is to improve the accuracy
of your RAG architectures.
Now why is it important?
Because A, first of all,
you are putting your enterprise data set
in front of in your
generative AI applications
and you're making certain decisions on it.
And now the concept of
user is also changed.
It's not only just a human
who's going to be maybe querying the RAG,
but it is also autonomous systems.
Your agent DKI systems
are also querying the RAG architectures.
In those cases, it's important
to make sure your retrieval
quality is improved
as well as your response is improved.
And that's the idea that we
are going to talk about today.
So everyone knows RAG,
so we're not going to dive
what is RAG in action.
Just a reminder, RAG is again
retrieval and generation,
two main components,
but let's not forget the
ingestion of the documents.
And now for purpose of this session,
we are going to be focused
on unstructured data
because that's where we see
a lot of issues that occur
with respect to improving
your RAG accuracy.
And unstructured could be
documents, could be images,
could be your videos,
or it could be a mixture of those things.
So document the data ingestion workflow
is extremely important.
There are certain techniques
that you can apply during
the data ingestion workflow
so that the information
that is getting into the
vector store is stored well.
So chunking strategy,
maybe doing more transformation
on the chunks, et cetera.
We won't get time to focus on that today.
We'll focus on the retrieval
and the generation part of it.
So the next is again,
when the retrieval part,
when the users are asking questions,
you are retrieving specific chunks
and then you are applying a model,
sending to LLM to generate
the response for the user.
So having said that,
for those who are not familiar
with Amazon Bedrock Knowledge Bases,
it is a managed feature,
it's a managed service for
your end-to-end RAG workflow.
So as we saw earlier,
when you put together RAG architecture,
you need to have select
an embedding model.
You need to select chunking strategy,
you need to select what
kind of vector store
you are going to use.
You need to select a LLM
that is going to generate the information.
So there are few components
that come into picture
and they need to
integrate with each other.
So Bedrock Knowledge Bases
gives you that end-to-end RAG workflow.
With few configurations
you can put that together very quickly.
And from the data source perspective,
S3 is a main data source,
but again,
there are multiple data
sources you can connect to
such as SharePoint,
confluence types, et cetera.
And we are going to see a lot about
Knowledge Bases in the code.
So now we have, we defined,
okay, we have a RAG architecture.
Now majority of the times,
initially when you get started,
maybe in the POC phase et cetera,
you are going to have
your unstructured data,
put that in the vector store
and start asking questions.
Standard RAG.
So some of you may know
it as naive RAG as well.
So basically at that point in time
we are not doing additional pre-processing
or any post-processing after
that context is retrieved.
However, and this works fine
if you have in certain cases,
especially if you have,
in my experience, if you have let's say
not a huge volume of documents
or the documents are
fairly straightforward,
they are not interconnected
with each other
or maybe there's not too
much proprietary data
or abbreviations that are around it,
standard RAG works just fine.
However, as you move towards
complex applications,
then it all depends on your,
well how complex your documents are.
Do you have large number of documents?
Sometimes you may have
more than 10,000 documents
and suddenly things
start getting interesting
with respect to RAG architectures.
You may have your users,
their usage pattern is
also hugely dependent
because they may be asking some
complex queries, et cetera.
So how those RAG systems are being used,
that's also important.
So in all those cases, then
things start getting interesting
and that's where you
need to start focusing on
the quality of retrieval and responses.
So this is where advanced
RAG architecture pattern
comes into picture.
So advanced RAG is again,
it's a technique that's going
to enhance your standard RAG
and the idea is to enrich your retrieval
and generation responses.
Now there are two main
prominent categories
that are out there.
Again, these are common,
there are others also,
and this is a constantly evolving field,
so there are new papers that
are published all the time.
But these are the things
that are the most common patterns,
is going to be a conditional branching
and parallel branching.
Let's take a quick look at
what that before we proceed.
So conditional branching now.
So as you start putting more generic
or more complex generative
AI applications,
you're not restricted to data
within just one vector store.
You will have applications
where you will have multiple vector stores
that you need to query.
In those cases,
you need to basically your
generative AI applications
or it could be an agent
that needs to make a decision,
well which vector store
do I need to query from?
And that is where the
conditional branching
will come into picture.
Let's take an example.
I hope everyone was shopping
during the Thanksgiving.
Let's say you have a query about a product
and there is a customer
support generative AI agent
that's answering your questions.
If there is a specific
query about the product,
the agent should be intelligent enough
to go to that particular
product-related vector store.
But if you have,
let's say a question about
well what is the return policy
for that particular
item that you're buying?
In those cases it will go around
the policy-related vector store.
So that's the conditional branching.
However, things are not so binary.
It's not so black and white anymore.
You want to have data coming in
from multiple vector stores
and then making decisions from it.
For example, if you are, let's say,
let's take a manufacturing example.
On the factory floor,
maybe an instrument is
showing an error code
or somebody notices a condition
that certain equipment is not working well
and you have a generative AI application
that's going to A, give you a root cause
for that particular error code.
But would you stop there?
Why would you stop there?
Once you know what is the root cause
for that particular error code,
you are going to get,
well how to fix it.
Is there any step by step instruction?
Is there an instruction manual around it?
So you will want to get
that information as well
and present it to the user.
You may also take an action upon it
saying that okay, this might
be a potential root cause
and this may be a part that is required.
Can I order it? Do I have that in stock?
So you can see that there are multiple,
you are getting the data from multiple
enterprise data sources.
Then you are ranking and pooling that data
and giving the right
information to your user.
So that's where the parallel branching
will come into picture.
Now, well we said yes,
there are different vector
stores we can connect to
and now fantastic,
I'm getting my chunks
but does that still improve your retrieval
and generation quality?
No. So there are certain
going to be again,
what is the pattern of your usage,
how your users are querying that pattern
and that is where additional techniques
that need to be applied.
Now we are going to walk through
a couple of techniques in the code,
but query reformulation
is one of the most common
techniques that we have seen.
And again, there are additional techniques
you're going to be
re-ranking results et cetera.
We'll cover a few of them at the end.
But the query reformulation
is one of the most common
practices that we have seen
our customers employ.
And what is the query formulation?
Basically from your usage patterns,
you will see that if the query
and majority of the time that
query will have subqueries
or it's a multi-part query
or a complex query that is associated.
In those cases,
that query will be broken
down into multiple pieces,
then all the queries would be fired up
against the vector store.
It will collect the relevant context
or chunks from the vector store
and then it is going to rank
and pull the right response.
So this is where the query
reformulation comes into picture
and Amazon Bedrock Knowledge Bases
does have a feature
where you can configure
this particular orchestration feature
and get started with it.
So having said that, we are
going to go to the code.
Okay, so for the purpose of this code now,
okay, thank you.
Thank you, Vivek.
So we are going to execute
the code in Jupyter Notebook.
So first of all, for this particular code
we have taken a example of
a financial analyst company.
So Octank is a fictitious company.
It has produced a 10-K report
and the 10-K report is
also generated by LLMs.
It's all, it's completely synthetic data.
So idea is we have put together
generative AI application
that is going to help
some analysts ask question
around that 10-K document.
Now in order to do that,
we definitely need a few things.
We need to A, first
upload that 10-K document
to an S3 bucket.
So which we have already pre-provision.
We also have pre-provision
in Knowledge Base
because it does take two to five minutes
for the knowledge base to come up
with all the different components
and the data to be ingested.
And again we are at the
mercy of internet God,
so I didn't wanna take a chance
of something going wrong.
So the knowledge base is
already pre-populated.
Having said that, we'll
step through the code.
So this is the agentic RAG
notebook that we have seen.
Now one thing is there
and we will clarify why there
is a DynamoDB table also
that we have provisioned.
The DynamoDB table is going to
be storing glossary of text.
So we have some proprietary abbreviations
that our company uses.
So those that the glossary of terms
has been stored in DynamoDB.
We have chosen DynamoDB for
the demonstration purpose.
You could choose any
any different storage,
like you could have it in S3
or anywhere or in the memory itself.
So we are going to install
the necessary libraries.
And just quick look at
the requirement TXT,
we have boto3,
OpenSearch is the underlying vector store
that we are using
and the different
frameworks that are there.
And we're going to talk about
some of these frameworks
during our conversation.
So this part, since the requirement .TXT
and the notebook we have already started,
so let's focus on the next part.
So now there are going to be
some configurations set up.
We are using Haiku 4.5 as our model
to generate the response on the context.
Naturally, first thing we need
is the right AWS credentials.
So we are just making sure
there is nothing coming from the memory
and then we are setting
up the right credentials.
Now here we are going to be basically
looking at the standard.
First of all we need a boto3 library
and then we are getting
additional libraries
that are required.
So we are getting the
handle on our AWS session
and we are going to quickly make sure
everything looks good
from our connectivity purposes.
And yup, I have the account,
I have the right region
and things are things look good.
Now.
So setting up and
creating a knowledge base.
And this is already executed
so I'm not going to execute
this particular code
but I'm going to explain what this does.
So this is where we are going to specify
the knowledge base name
and the description
so that you have.
Now the bucket name
that I'm specifying here
is going to house my 10-K document.
So that's where I'm
creating a bucket first
and going to house my 10-K document.
Once that is done,
then I'm going to use
the Bedrock create knowledge base API.
Now here you will see
that there are few parameters
that we are providing.
Again, we set the name and description
for the knowledge base.
The data source is there, which is S3.
Now the chunking strategy,
I'm not disturbing it.
I have a 10-K document
which I know is going to flow through.
I'm going to use the
fixed-size chunking strategy.
So I'm going to specify a few parameters
for me to create the
Bedrock knowledge base.
However, let's take a look
at what it initializes.
So this is my,
it's a utility, that knowledge_base.py.
And then as you can see,
there are a few things that
I've already initialized
as part of my class initializer.
So if you look at this,
I have already selected
what kind of embedding
model I want to choose.
So I'm using Titan embedding.
you can use Cohere also,
Cohere is also available.
Then from the generation model,
here by default we have selected
three, if nobody specifies,
but we are overriding
that with the Haiku 4.5.
And chunking strategy is also fixed-size.
But I wanted to show
these arguments to you
so that when you are
applying knowledge bases
within your own systems,
there are going to be
different decision points
that you can make.
You can choose your vector store as well.
So knowledge bases support
OpenSearch as a vector store
under which is the default one.
But you can also have S3 vectors.
You can have (speaking indistinctly)
and we'll keep coming up
with the new connection.
So you can definitely define
the vector store that you need.
So this is where,
and then again that is going
to be the chunking strategy.
We do support fixed chunking.
That is a default one that you can select,
but you can also select semantic chunking
or hierarchical chunking
based on your use case.
And once we have done,
so this is where all the
initializers that are happening.
Now there is a lambda function,
lambda client also that you see.
So if you're looking to get
basically while chunking,
if you need to pre-process
the chunks additionally
to extract additional insights from that,
you can do that by using lambda function.
So that is an option that is available.
So you set up your knowledge base
and there are a bunch of other features
but I think just I wanted
to highlight the main ones.
So using that, now we have
created the knowledge base
and this is where we are uploading
the Octank financial 10-K document.
So this is basically the 10-K document
that our LLM has generated
and that's the document
that we will be ingesting.
Now the next step once you
create the knowledge base
is to start the ingestion job.
We are not purposefully
executing these cells
because these do take a minute or so
and we have limited time.
So this is something basically
we have already executed
but this is where from your data store
if it is the first time
it's going to ingest all the documents
but subsequent runs,
any incremental files
that are dropped within the data source
or if there is an update,
that will be ingested when
you start the sync job.
So once you ingest those documents,
now our knowledge base is ready
and we can start with the basic RAG flow.
So I'm going to execute
this particular cell
and as you can see,
I have my knowledge base ID
and DynamoDB which is already created.
First, this is the DynamoDB
table that creates,
and it's just dumps basically,
inserts these particular glossary records
into the DynamoDB table
that we will be using.
So now let's execute the basic RAG flow.
Okay, so now once you
have your knowledge base
that is created,
you have access to two different APIs.
One is going to be retrieve API
and the second one is going
to be retrieve and generate.
So Bedrock Knowledge Bases retrieve API
is going to give you just the handle
to the context to the chunks
and then you are free to basically
if you wanna post process,
if there is additional
steps that you wanna do
or if you may have a small model
that you have already defined
or you already have an endpoint
and then you want to generate
the responses using that,
you can use the retrieve API.
For our purposes, we are
focusing on retrieve and generate
where it is going to not
only retrieve the data
from the vector store
but it's also going to use the
LLM that we have identified,
which is the Haiku
and generate those specific responses.
So let's look at the
knowledge base configuration
for retrieval purposes.
So here we have set that
for retrieval configuration,
the vector search configuration,
the number of results
you can return is five.
Five is the default. We
are keeping it as is.
You can retrieve up to 99 different chunks
from the vector store.
But again, right, and then this
is a completely configurable
but by default it is
going to retrieve five.
I'm not specifying anything else
within this particular
retrieval configuration
to demonstrate what the
basic RAG flow looks like.
So now, once we have
three different questions
that we are going to ask
to this 10-K document.
The first one is what is the
fair value of HTM portfolio?
Then what are the main business segments
of Octank Financial,
and how many employees
does Octank Financial have?
Fairly basic question,
my financial analyst
doesn't trust the system.
They said, "Okay, let me
just give it a test run
and let me see what it does."
So fantastic.
We are going to execute this
and let's see what our
RAG comes out to be.
Okay, it is able to find
the HTM portfolio value
and it is also able to generate the,
so here it did, let me highlight that.
So this is where it did find the answer
for the HTM portfolio.
For the second one also,
what are the main segments
of Octank Financial?
It did come up with fairly
comprehensive answer.
And for how many employees,
also it does have that information, right?
So let's investigate what happened here.
So in our document,
I'm going to just type in
to say whether HTM is existing.
And as you can see,
within the text itself,
HTM is clearly defined.
So the standard RAG
or the basic RAG
had no trouble finding the right chunks
and we were able to
retrieve those documents.
Now our financial analysts
are feeling confident
and they say okay,
let us start querying the things
that we basically do it most of the times
that we are going to operationally use.
So some of the test
questions that they have
are a little bit more.
Oops. Yeah, first one.
- [Vivek] Yeah.
- [Pallavi] So the first
question that we have
is what is Octank Tower
and how does the whistleblower scandal
hurt the company and its image?
Second one is provide list of DCMS,
and provide list of DCMS and
how many regional offices?
So I am going to execute
this part and let's see.
Okay.
So the first query, it did say
it could not find any
information about Octank Tower,
but it did find information
specifically about the whistleblower.
Now let's inspect our document.
Let's see what we have
in the whistleblower.
So there is a clearly section
that identifies the
whistleblower document.
So this is why
partially, the RAG
system is able to answer,
and does it have information
for the Octank Tower?
Well, it does
but it is not being pulled into your,
so it does identify there's a headquarter
at Octank Tower
but that information is not present
in your context that you have
retrieved from vector store.
That's why that information is not present
in the final output that you have given.
So this is where we
need to then figure out,
well, what are the techniques
that how we can improve
and make sure all the user questions
are relatively answered?
And the third question
also, about the DCM,
well, let's see if we
have anything on the DCM.
So I was encouraged by HTM
thinking DCM will also
be very well defined
but I do not find anything on DCM
because that's the company abbreviation
of the proprietary data
that is being used.
So now we want to improve
that RAG accuracy.
So the first one that we are
going to employ the technique
is going to be decompose and generate.
And as we talked about it earlier,
is we are going to reformulate the query,
which is we are going to
break down those query
into multiple parts
and then query our RAG application.
So if you look at this,
at this point in time,
my configuration that I'm going to supply
to the knowledge base,
I'm still keeping my vector
search configuration same,
however, I'm adding new
orchestration configuration.
Orchestration configuration
is going to let the knowledge base know
that before you send this response,
you need to basically
have additional enrichment steps
onto that particular query.
And this is where I'm
saying query transformation,
use the type as query decomposition.
So that's all I'm going to specify.
I'm not going to have any additional steps
or any additional piece of
code that I need to write.
At this point in time,
I'm going to have Bedrock Knowledge Bases
use this managed service
to decompose the query for me
and we are going to then similar
retrieve and generate call
the same API call that we executed.
So that's what we have.
Now we are going to just
test one question for now
to see how it does.
So the first question I ask,
what is the Octank Tower
and how does the whistleblower
scandal hurt its image?
It has already said
that I'm going to use the
decompose and generate
and it is able to now associate
what is my Octank Tower
and how does it basically,
the whistleblower scandal affect
and we are able to sort of
synthesize the response.
What do you think will
happen if I query DCM?
Do you think it will find it?
No, because at that point in time,
even if I'm having DCM,
DCM the query, it still doesn't know.
So even the query decomposition feature
at this point in time
is not going to help
because there is really, it's
not a multi-part question.
So how do we solve that?
And that is where we are going
to use the query expansion.
Now query expansion,
sure you're hearing all the
agentic tools, et cetera.
So we are going to basically define a tool
that is going to now do a lookup
on our proprietary abbreviations,
which is going to be in the DynamoDB table
and get the relevant data.
So we are using Strands Agent
for this particular purposes.
It's again, it's our Bedrock
SDK, to create agents.
It's fairly straightforward
but you can choose any other framework
to create that particular agent.
So we are defining it at the tools.
So that's one of the tools
that agent has access to.
So look up chunk,
you're going to be basically querying
against the DynamoDB table
and now I have given
the project expression
as I need to expand upon those terms,
so go get me the term definitions.
So when I look at that, if
I'm going to expand the query,
so the function query_expansion
is going to expand the
query using term definition
via intelligent agent-based lookup.
So it's giving me that,
okay, I need to go query
the tool right now.
So here I have created my agent,
I've provided the name,
the model ID, I'm still using Haiku 4.5.
And the system prompt, now
I'm letting the agent know
that you have access
to this particular tool
and in tools, I have also
defined that as a lookup term.
I've given the information
that you have access to
this particular tool.
So now go and get the definition
from the term glossary
and then expand upon it.
And then there are specific instructions
for this particular agent
to call the lookup term for each relevant.
And it can call multiple times
because your query may
have multiple questions.
So once that prompt gets executed,
we are going to then
transform this question
using relevant term definition.
So let's execute and see what happens.
So at that point in time,
the question still remains,
provide the list of DCMs.
Now it knows that the DCM
is the term that it needs to expand.
Now the result is disclosure
committee members.
Oh, DCM stands for
disclosure committee members.
That means I need to now
go look at the document
and fetch those results.
So that's where I got
these particular results.
There are three particular
individuals though
who are part of the
disclosure committee members.
Now we walked through two techniques.
Fantastic.
Based on each user preference,
can we define which technique
to use or instruct any user?
No, we need a better way
of an agentic approach
to identify which particular technique
needs to be applied based on user query
and that's where Vivek
is going to step through
the self-corrective RAG.
- [Vivek] Thanks Pallavi.
So you saw the different techniques
and like Pallavi said,
we need a way that
based on the user query,
it is automatically able to decide
which particular technique
do I need to use?
Whether I need to use the basic RAG
or I need to use query expansion
or I need to use a query decomposition
or maybe some other technique.
That's where self-corrective
agentic RAG come into picture.
So you have a agent loop
and then you have the
different components.
These components are nothing
but these are the different
techniques that you can utilize.
And using that, we develop the
self-corrective agentic RAG.
So with self-corrective agentic RAG,
you have a user question
which is supplied to a central agent.
Now this central agent will
first retrieve the context
out of the data source.
This context will then be analyzed.
It will be checked
whether this context is
relevant to the user question.
And based on whether
the context is relevant
to the user question or not,
it will select one of the strategies.
It may be a query expansion,
it can be a query decomposition,
it can be a combination of the two.
Yeah.
And once we have selected
the appropriate technique,
then the response needs to be generated
after the context is
augmented to the user query
and ask the LLM.
Now once we have the response,
we again want to check
whether this response
is relevant to the user question.
This is the second check.
First we did the context relevance
and now we are doing the
response relevance check.
Now within the response
relevance check itself,
we want to check the
relevance of the user query
to the response.
Then we also want to check the
completeness of the response
and we also want to check
the factual accuracy
of the response.
And based on that,
we will either again loop back
to select the appropriate strategy again
if the answer is not good enough
or if the answer is good,
then we have the answer directly
and we will loop till
we get the right answer
or we reach a maximum threshold
so that it doesn't go into infinite loop.
That's the self-corrective
agentic RAG architecture.
Simple one that we are going
to walk through the code.
Yeah.
So let's look at some real code now.
Thanks Pallavi.
So Pallavi already covered
few of the techniques,
the basic RAG,
then the query expansion,
the query decomposition.
We will be adding two
more techniques over here.
One is retrieving the document.
Pallavi touched based upon it earlier
where using knowledge-based retrieve API,
we can just retrieve the
context out of the vector store.
So we will use this tool
which is an additional tool
and we are adding another
function over here
which will evaluate the
quality of the response
which is generated from the LLM.
So this is another tool
and as we discussed earlier,
it will be based on the relevance,
the factual accuracy and the
accuracy of the response.
So let's look at it.
So we will first create
all these five tools
that we just see.
The initial tool, retrieve documents tool.
Here we are using retrieve API.
This is a knowledge base API.
We just provide the KPID and the question,
it will be able to get the
response out of the vector store
and provide the chunks to us.
So that's the only thing it is doing.
We are not using retrieve and generate,
just the retrieve API.
Yeah.
This is also useful in some cases
where there are certain LLMs
which are provided by Knowledge Bases.
But say you want to use your custom model.
So in that case you can
retrieve the document
using retrieve API
and then generate the response
using your own custom LLM.
Yeah.
So this tool is defined now.
Retrieve and generate.
This is exactly the same tool
that Pallavi already went over,
so I'll skip over it.
Retrieve and generate API.
Decompose and generate.
This is again the same tool.
Pallavi already went over it.
We are using the same API,
retrieve and generate.
The only change here
is query decomposition
as the query transformation configuration.
Yeah.
Now, query expansion agent.
So this query expansion agent,
it's written using strengths agent
which is open source SDK provided by AWS
which is used for writing agents.
You can write agent code
using the strengths agent.
You have Creao AI, you have
LangChain which you can use.
Over here we have used Strands Agent.
So with Strands Agent,
I have defined the agent,
which is query_expansion_agent_tool.
ModelID lookup_term.
This is the same tool that
Pallavi already defined
and lookup_term is the tool
for this query expansion agent.
Yeah.
So this, we already went over the code.
So I will go to the next
tool, which is the last tool,
evaluate the response quality with agent.
Now here again, I'm using agent.
This is a agent which is a tool, right?
So I will come over how to use this
within the central agent.
So here again I define the agent.
I provided the name of
the agent, the model,
which model I want to use.
So here, if you see the
model that I'm using,
it's a different agent.
It's a qualityCheckModelId.
I'm using Claude Sonnet 4.5 here.
So earlier you see for the basic RAG
we are using Claude Haiku 4.5
which is a lighter and a faster model.
Here I wanted a reasoning model
and I wanted a model
which has more parameters.
So I'm using Claude Sonnet 4.5 over here.
So depending on the use case,
you choose the right model.
And then I'm providing a system prompt.
Now here in the system prompt,
like we discussed earlier,
I have provided a evaluation criteria
where I wanted to check based
on the relevance, completeness
and the factual accuracy of the response
and provide that,
okay this is the quality
score according to that
and that's it.
So this agent is defined.
Now I have all my tools defined
and you would have noticed
some of the tools were mere functions
and some of the tools
were actually subagents.
Now, I need to create a central agent
which can orchestrate the flow
between all these different tools.
That's where I will
create the central agent
and again, I'm using Strands Agent
for writing the central agent.
So here, first I have
defined all the tools.
The tools have already been defined here,
I have just suggested
that these are the tools
which are there.
And then, same way I'm creating the agent,
I'm defining the name of the agent,
I'm defining that this is the model ID.
Here also, I wanted to
use quality check model ID
which is Claude Sonnet 4.5.
These are the all the tools that you have.
And then I'm providing a system prompt
suggesting the same
flow which we discussed
as part of the flow
diagram in the presentation
where you have to first
retrieve the chunks
then do the chunk relevancy check
and this particular agent will do that.
And here, if you would have noticed it,
I'm using LLM-as-a-Judge concept
for doing the context relevancy check
and as well as later on for
quality relevance check.
So both our LLM-as-a-Judge concept.
There are different
tools which are available
like RAG checker or RAGAs
which you can also use.
Those are open-source tools
for doing the context relevancy check
and the response relevancy check.
Here I'm using plain
LLM-as-a-Judge concept.
And once I have defined
this central agent,
so let's execute these cells, right?
So first, I'll execute the cell
where I'm creating all the tools
and once I have all the
tools created or defined,
let me execute the cell
where it creates the central agent
and now I need to kick
off the central agent.
This piece of code,
it just calling the central
agent that we just defined.
Rest of the code is just
for the display purpose
so that the output is displayed
so that you can understand that.
Here, I will be asking the same questions
that Pallavi just went over.
The first two questions are
plain and simple question
and then the rest of the three questions
are a little bit complex question.
So we'll see how
the corrective central
agent behaves over here.
Let me execute this particular cell.
Okay, so the first question,
what is fair value of STM portfolio?
It first used retrieve documents tool
to retrieve the chunks out
of the vector database.
Once it has the chunks out,
it will do the chunk relevancy check.
So here it checks. Excellent.
The retrieved documents contain
highly relevant information
that directly answers the question.
So it is satisfied with that.
So it checked which strategy should I use.
I already have the relevant chunk.
Let me use the basic RAG strategy
where it used retrieve and generate tool
and it found the answer,
the fair value of
held-to-maturity portfolio
was dollar 1.2 billion as
of December 31st, 2021.
Now I have the response.
I want to do the quality of
the response check as well.
So I will check the response quality.
So this is the quality inspection
agent which is triggered
and it found that it is relevant.
The completeness is also good
and the factual accuracy is also good.
So overall quality is good. Excellent.
So it identified it as the final answer.
It didn't go to the loop again.
It found the answer. This is the answer.
So the simple answer,
it used basic RAG technique
and it got the answer.
Now let's go to the second question
which is what are the
main business segments
of Octank Financial?
So here again, retrieve
documents as the first tool.
Got the chunks, let's check
the relevancy of these chunks.
Corresponding to the question,
the retrieve documents contain
highly relevant information
about Octank financial.
The context is clear and
directly addresses the question.
So it determined that I need to use
retrieve and generate,
which is a basic RAG
and it found the answer response
saying that okay,
these are the different
investment banking divisions
which are there.
Once it has the response,
it again did the response quality check.
The response is relevant, highly relevant,
10 out of 10.
Complete and factual
accuracy is also good.
So the quality is good. Excellent.
It used basic RAG
and it found the answer
within one go itself.
For the first two questions, we are good.
Let's move to the next question,
which is provide the list of DCMs.
And as Pallavi showed earlier,
DCM is not even defined in the PDF.
So let's see how it behaves over here.
It did the retrieve
documents, it found chunks,
it did the chunk
relevancy check over here.
When it did the chunk relevancy,
it sees that I can see
that the retrieve documents
are about Octank Financial data centers
committee and corporate governance.
So this is how it internally expanded,
but they don't specifically
address DCMs as a list.
So the chunks are not
relevant to the question.
So it used query expansion agent.
Let me try to expand DCM.
So it used lookup term
query expansion subagent.
And within the query expansion subagent,
it used the lookup term.
It found the definition of DCM,
disclosure committee member
and it provided a new question saying that
provide the list of
disclosure committee members.
Now let's ask this question.
It used retrieve and generate
and it found the answers to the question.
And then once I have the answer,
I have to do the response relevance check.
So let's do the response relevant check.
Relevance is good,
completeness is also good.
Factual accuracy is okay.
The status is good,
overall quality is good.
So it selected this as the final answer
and suggested that okay,
I used query expansion,
then I used the basic RAG.
The quality is good.
Specifically, it's checking
the response relevance,
which is good.
And it found the answer to the question
with one attempt.
Now let's go to the fourth question.
What is Octank Tower
and how does the whistleblower scandal
hurt the company and its image?
Now again, it will do the same thing.
It will retrieve the documents,
it will check the relevancy of the chunks
which are retrieved.
It sees that it has two parts.
It is able to identify
that, what is Octank Tower
and how does whistleblower
scandal hurt the company?
It found that the whistleblower
scandal information is there
but it doesn't notice any information
related to Octank Tower.
Now since it identified
it's a multi-part question,
it straight away used
decompose and generate tool.
It found out the answer,
Octank Tower is this.
And then the whistleblower scandal also,
it found out the answer related to that.
The whistleblower scandal
involving person X, right?
Now, once I have this response
from decompose and generate,
I have to do the response relevance check.
So the response relevance check is done,
the relevance is high,
which is most important.
Completeness is good,
factual accuracy is good.
So it selected this as the final answer.
It used decompose and
generate and found the answer.
Now let's go to the last one.
Provide list of DCMs and
how many regional offices.
Again, it did the retrieve document.
Check the relevance of
the retrieved documents.
It doesn't found
information related to DCMs,
so it used query expansion tool
to find the information about DCM.
Disclosure the committee member.
Now here you see it didn't
use retrieve and generate
because it identified this,
it is a two-part question,
multi-part question.
So here, after query expansion,
it used decompose and generate
and it found out the answer
which is suggesting disclosure
committee members are these.
And then these are the regional offices
which are within North
America, Europe, Asia,
and Oceania.
And last I have to now do
the response quality check.
So relevance, the answer is in fact
relevant to the question,
it is complete.
Factual accuracy is also good.
So it identified it as a good candidate
and oh, it actually identified
some of the recommendations
for improvement.
So it again went for retrieve
and generate this time
and okay, it found,
okay, query expansion,
decomposition, basic RAG.
Again, the quality is similar
to what it was earlier
and it identified that okay,
I have the final answer.
I tried decompose and
generate and I got the answer.
This is also similar quality.
So it used that as the final answer,
which is disclosure
committee members are this
and these are the regional offices.
So yeah, this is how you see
how the self-corrective agentic RAG work
where based on the central agent,
it is able to utilize
the appropriate strategy.
And again, we have quality inspection
and the chunk inspection
as few of the strategies
that it is using for doing the looping.
Now these are a few of the
techniques that we have,
but there are several different
techniques which are there,
but we have limited time.
So that's where we have to actually,
I just want to touch upon
few of the other techniques
which are there as well.
So Pallavi touched upon ingestion flow
as well as the retrieval flow.
And within the ingestion flow,
you can enhance the quality of the chunks
and the embeddings,
which will be ultimately
stored in the vector database,
which helps in ultimately improving
the retrieval accuracy as well.
So some of the strategies
are chunking strategies.
We used fixed chunking over here,
but there are other chunking strategies
like semantic chunking
where it keeps the
semantically similar embeddings
near to each other
so that within the same chunk
you can find it.
Other strategies,
foundation model parsing.
So say you have a document
which has a lot of images,
graphs, these kind of things.
Then you might first want
to use foundation model
to actually ingest the
data out of the document
and then ingest that data
within the vector store.
So this is another
technique which can be used.
Multimodal parsing is another thing
where say you have images within your PDF
and when you are retrieving the documents
and we are generating the answer,
you want to show the images
also as along with the answer.
So that's where the multimodal
parsing come into picture.
Metadata labeling is another technique
where you can define that okay,
you have multiple documents
within your data source
and you want to label it
so that when you are asking question,
depending on your question,
it will identify
I have to use this
particular label document
and it can directly get
the answer from there.
These are few of the techniques
for the ingestion flow.
Then we have certain techniques
within the retrieval flow.
We touched upon several techniques here,
but the metadata filtering
is another technique
where we can use the metadata.
We can specify that say for example,
you have a scenario where you have say
- [Pallavi] Large documents.
- [Vivek] English,
say there it's related
to educational domain
where you want to get an answer
for English or science.
So based on your metadata,
it can use the particular document
from your knowledge source
because it is labeled.
Re-ranking is another technique.
When you get the chunks
out of the vector store,
you actually want to re-rank them
so that most relevant chunks
are on the top of the search
and then it can find out
the answer out of that.
Hybrid search is another technique
where you can use the
combination of semantic chunking,
semantic search and the keyword search.
So with semantic search,
you get the semantically similar answer,
but sometimes you want
to use the keyword search
for exact answers
so it can identify which
is the best technique
and it it can use in
that particular technique
for answering the question.
So these are a few of the
techniques which you can use
for further enhancing your RAG accuracy.
And these are some of the blogs and papers
that you would like to just have with you
and look at it for some further learning.
Yeah.
We are open for questions.
We have seven more minutes
and we'll try to answer as
many questions as we can,
but we have to leave
at the end of the hour
so we will be available outside
for any further questions.
- [Pallavi] And I think just to conclude,
I mean we did see the whole goal for us
was to mainly divide this into
first context relevancy check
and then the retrieval relevancy
to improve your RAG accuracy.
And that's where sort of the decisioning
with the self-corrective
RAG came into picture
is to identify.
So just when you are thinking about
how do I improve the accuracy of the RAG,
think the document ingestion,
think about the context relevancy.
That's the first thing you can check.
And the retrieval relevancy.